hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday and I'm just checking it
on you just checking it on you seeing
how you're doing you having a good week
hmm are you enjoying yourself I hope you
having a good [ __ ] week I hope it's
going better than my week hope it's
going better than my week I don't know
if I'll [ __ ] it I'll get right into it
unfortunately a great comedian great
friend just one of the best people ever
met passed away yesterday Charlie Murphy
and I can't [ __ ] believe it man
really cannot believe it I had hadn't
talked to him in about a year and I had
no idea that uh that he was sick to that
level so I think it still hit me man
it's unbelievable I'm so sick of [ __ ]
hilarious great people dying I was
actually talking with the friend of mine
the other day I was just like dude two
hacks ever died like what it when was
the last time somebody who truly sucked
at that stand-up comedy died it's
[ __ ] unbelievable
what a hacks eat this cake if I was if I
had the [ __ ] money I swear to god I
get I get to man you know maybe it's all
you know what's funny I actually realize
halfway through this that I'm still
alive so when I kind of [ __ ] on
myself somebody's got to put together
the hack diet whatever that is those
[ __ ] lived to be like 85 90
anyways another just giant I mean you're
talking about somebody who when I met
him in 2004 had already lived like four
lifetimes he had four unbelievable books
from his childhood to his teenage years
in early 20s living in Brooklyn and all
this [ __ ] that he did to going into the
Navy to his brother blowing up and then
him getting out of the Navy and working
security on the tour
and then morphing in to like a
screenwriter an actor and then he gets
on the Chappelle show tell just was
sitting around as was that was told to
me just telling these stories of you
know back in the day hanging out with
everyone from Prince to Rick James
you've seen all those things stories
about Whitney Houston he just Sugar Ray
Leonard Oh Jay Simpson he just like that
sketch which to this day I'm telling you
is I think it's the greatest sketch of
all time the Charlie Murphy's true
Hollywood story about Rick James and I
remember him telling me afterwards I was
just like dude how true is that [ __ ] and
he goes well yeah obviously we
exaggerate like you know he didn't when
he hit me in the head I didn't have a
unity you know thing on my head but he's
like yeah he did they were like in the
back of the limo or something and you
know Rick just kind of went - he was
trying to be like friendly but like I
had he kind of hit Charlie like hard
enough in the head that I guess Eddie
and his friends were waiting for Charlie
react because they knew what Charlie was
and Charlie kind of got mine [ __ ] for
half a second thinking like you know I'd
stomp the [ __ ] out of anybody who did
this to me but it's Rick James and it
kind of took him like an hour before he
was like [ __ ] this and I you know
obviously didn't kick him up on a
dresser but he did [ __ ] rough him up
a little bit in the back room and then
when his security came in he did bring
him over to the window and say that he
was gonna throw him out
they came anywhere near oh so yeah man
it's just really really a sad day and
that guy was just he was such a great
guy I told you guys a story before he
saved my [ __ ] ass one time I was
trying to get in shape right as always
as I always am I was living in New York
City and I started going down to
Gleason's Gym out in Brooklyn you know
cuz I didn't want to get all [ __ ] you
know I was just wink is I believe what I
was calling myself for they were giving
me [ __ ] cuz I just went down there and
an actor performer kind of wait
get in boxing shape without ever [ __ ]
you know getting my head kicked in so
when I told Charlie that I was going
down to Gleason's Gym he goes as I'm
going oh yeah okay
okay I'm gonna tell you what's going to
happen because you'll be oh they have
about six weeks and I don't know where
he goes some dudes gonna come up to you
and start telling you be like how long
you've been boxing for really ah man you
nice man you night you we had a spar
some time he goes he's gonna [ __ ]
he's gonna amp you all up to get you
into the ring so he can try out a bunch
of [ __ ] that he does that he's not dumb
enough to try out on a professional
boxer and he's gonna beat the [ __ ] out
of you and I was a sight and he just
started laughing at me I'm like I get to
[ __ ] out he get to [ __ ] a dude I'm
telling you I was like whatever time he
said three weeks of six weeks it was
like right on the nose I'm sitting there
you know on the heavy bag like the
comedian slash sometimes actor I am
hitting the bag like right and this
[ __ ] black dude shredded comes over
he's like yo man he go how long human a
long big box before it was like it was
almost like Charlie's head was on the
guy's head he said the exact same thing
oh man you nice man you ought to get in
the [ __ ] ring in all this [ __ ] I just
started laughing I just started laughing
I was like I go man [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I got a
[ __ ] comedian
I'm horrific I'm not getting in this you
can try out all your new [ __ ] on me and
the guy just started laughing threw his
head back laughed and then walked away
and it was so weird I was like that guy
was gonna beat the [ __ ] out of me so
then I told it to Charlie thinking that
he would be amazed that you know you
know like like dude I called it what the
[ __ ] did I say and he was just like yeah
he's like I told you he did that like a
million times like he just had this I
don't know he had like this [ __ ]
sixth sense and I tell you some of those
other stories the oj1 and the Whitney
one but I just feel like those are him
there was what his stories to tell and
if he wanted to share me would have but
so I can only tell you the ones I've
ever I when we on that
Chappelle's Show tour was me
you know Donnell ashy Larry and him and
Charlie was the guy who actually showed
me that you could write a new hour of
material in two months because I saw him
do it
because he blew up you know on the
second season with that that Rick James
story and all this Donnell came up with
the idea for the tour he was like you
know yo son we should go out on tour bus
so you know we'll have bill open up you
know would bring you out Charlie you can
host it and then Donnell would close and
I think Charlie maybe did this is the
[ __ ] balls this guy had I think he
did maybe six shows before we did our
first show and I believe it was Dayton
Ohio and we didn't have an agent and
Donnell booked the thing and so we went
out there I was like the only white guy
in the room in the theater and we went
out there and Charley hosts and he went
out and just went Charlie my fare you
know I'm Rick James [ __ ] or something
like that place went [ __ ] nuts
he told like two more jokes brought me
out everybody's looking at me like who
the [ __ ] is this guy is this one of the
writers this is one of the creators is
this the agent on the tour nobody had
any idea who the [ __ ] I was so I did my
[ __ ] Charlie came out told another
couple of jokes in the Donnell closed
the show everybody had a great time and
afterwards we went into the back room
okay now we're in the green room and
it's like 20 people in there and we
don't know anybody once again I'm the
only white dude in there me Donnell and
Charlie are sitting at this table and
all of a sudden these two guys come up
was it one guy I can't remember and just
had like a [ __ ] bag of cash from that
night's gig and yet it all banded up and
just threw it on the table and it all
spilled out and it was just sitting
there and I was sitting there like what
the [ __ ] and Donnell and Charlie didn't
move so I didn't move and I was just
sitting there as the white dude like oh
I guess this is how black people pay
each other
20 complete strangers in the [ __ ]
room drinking and partying and then just
a bunch of cash I felt like we robbed a
bank or something so we sat there I
swear to God for at least one more Mobb
Deep's song or whatever the [ __ ] was
playing at that time the thong song I
can't remember whatever it was and
finally I forget it was either Donnell
or Charlie just sort of casually sat up
and just took the money put it in the
bag and then put it down by their side
which made me relax a little bit more
and I was just like I was sitting there
going like I don't think I'm ready for
this [ __ ] tour this is not the way
you get paid at the funny bone so we
stayed there maybe for like another half
hour and then we finally go up to get up
to leave and we're just walking out and
you just feeling eyeballs on us cuz we
got this big bet it's just cash and we
don't go out we get into the [ __ ]
they had rented this [ __ ] limo for us
we got in the car and the second the car
doors closed and we start driving away
Donnell just goes yo what the [ __ ] and
Charlie was just freaking out and I just
started and I was just like just the
Epiphany that they were actually
freaking out to it I had no idea you'd
never know looking at their face I'm
sure everybody in the room knew that I
was [ __ ] uncomfortable and suffice to
say after that we got ourselves an agent
and we get we got paid by check after
that it was just us in the room and that
was that infamous tour where they would
always make fun that's where that joke
came from you know this [ __ ] got
five shirts that's what that one came
from because they always made fun of my
clothes and that was that time when I
was hungover and I just didn't want to
get in the car and deal with this [ __ ]
and they had taught me about the itis
which was basically when you eat like a
food that's rich in flavor but low in
[ __ ] nutrition you body you end up
taking a quick catnap because your body
literally has to shut everything else
down to figure out how to digest what
you just put in your stomach so I was
standing outside this hotel
hungover as hell and I just saw oh my
god we were doing that it used to be the
UH it was the Chicago Zanies and then
you do Mount Vernon and then st. Charles
it was this three gig run through
Northern Illinois I forget where we go
we just done Janie's and I was too drunk
I had a [ __ ] headache and I'm walkin
out trying to get fresh air going I got
a deal with these two [ __ ] [ __ ]
all the way up to this club it's a
two-hour drive then non-stop going to be
[ __ ] hammer and me I looked down the
street there was a Popeyes and I just
remember them telling me about the itis
and I said [ __ ] this and I went down
there I got a bucket of chicken biscuits
with mashed potatoes gravy all of that
[ __ ] and I brought it into the end of
the [ __ ] limo I was like hey guys I
got some food that are great you know
they dug and they started eating and I
didn't have one piece of it and I swear
to god within twenty minutes they'll
both asleep and I had they slept the
entire [ __ ] ride I basically poisoned
upon temporary poison them and it worked
like a goddamn charm and I don't know I
just I I had to say something about
Charlie it's still too sad to really get
into the the feelings all this but he
truly was one not only one of the most
amazing just lives of anybody ever lived
he just was truly one of the best guys
that um that I ever met in this business
so
all right that's it no getting emotional
on the podcast okay so let's get back to
the rest of this stuff here um
the [ __ ] bro is huh finally the first
time all year we beat the Ottawa
Senators all right beat him when it
counts like I didn't even realize they
beat us all four times this year well
congratulations Ottawa capital of Canada
you know but unfortunately your floor
game winning streak came to an end right
when it counted you what the weirdest
part of that game was was listening to
loud Ottawa senator fence you know I
actually know something I used to think
that their fans would just lame but the
real reason is Ottawa it's just like
Washington DC you know it's the capital
so there's a bunch of people from all
over the [ __ ] country so there's a
bunch of Canuck fans flames boiler fans
all at [ __ ] this sitting there they
don't give a [ __ ] about the Senators you
know so it's not the people oughta WA
they're great people they got a little
[ __ ] River that they freeze over you
skate to work does not they mean it's
like a [ __ ] Fantasyland up there it's
one of my favorite cities I actually
like it for some reason they say Ottawa
the city that fund forgot well you know
what I always have a great time when I
go there um and what a [ __ ] great game
though Ottawa play great I by no means
think that victory means that we're
going to win the series I think it's
going to I think it was two to one I
feel like the whole series is going to
kind of go like that and it's going to
get even not even chippy I think it
might get a little ugly Brad Marchand
back from his suspension doing what he
does scoring big goals and big games hey
Nia come here I didn't know that Brad
Marchand where are you I never heard
this nickname Brad Marchand
they call him nose face killer because
and I thought I was being so original
when I called that guy on [ __ ] that's
delicious
because he sounds like Ghostface Killah
I call them pot roast
patro space killer and so no one's here
I am on my hack look at that
parallel thinking parallel thought there
you go
is that what it's called why do you know
what more than I do is that what said
behind my back no I'm doing I'm doing
all right
I'm doing all right the Bruins won in a
while no you haven't once you grab a mic
grab a microphone come on in here I'll
hit pause all right we're back I got the
microphone and everything like that the
lovely Nia hello how the hell how the
hell you been
I know a long time know podcast podcast
no I don't think you've really been on
that much since we had the little
princess here that's right
who's sitting here you know what's funny
is good you know her hair still short
and everything and all of our friends
had boys and they just gave us all their
clothes everyone keeps thinking it's a
boy and she just came in now she's got a
little shirt on that is like a classic
that looks like a 1955 Chevy pickup
truck on it so yeah so hey everyone yeah
everyone thinks that she is a boy but
that's okay she will not be defined by
her gender right yes she will I put on a
dress for God's sakes I like the little
boy clothes though I think they're so
cute well yeah I mean I don't care
either way
you know you look good to me that kid oh
yeah she doesn't have to be like all
frilly and princess looking I'm not
really into that anyway what are you
saying
so what do you mean at some point you
mean you got to put her with some girl's
clothes right yeah I plenty of girl's
clothes for her okay you're scaring me
there okay why what do you why why are
you scared well I mean at some point you
can't ever walking around like you know
Pete Carril Dockers and stuff you know
well now we're not going to do that but
like I think Hoshi
a little girl but I think little girls
look cute and like little boy clothes
like the little tomboy look I think
that's cute you know what as long as she
has clothes on and two diapers clean at
this point I'm happy if right I really
don't care what it is exactly but now so
anyways let me as she wore a cute little
address on Easter remember oh yes she
did I don't know what you would not not
East I want you at the Easter what so
the Easter bought it yeah Zoe we go to
church or anything like that
well he that's oh by the way Leah did I
tell you about that great band I saw the
other night oh you mean the one with
Davey Lich yeah look I haven't taken
drum lessons from you one of the best
drummers in the world right now
shoutout to Davey the that's right he
plays drums in this band called the
night game and they have a new single
out if you want to check it out its own
iTunes it's called the the outfield and
I saw them play like a quick half hour
sent the other night right uh over
Capitol Records where I cross the street
from that remember when I walked over
and then had Mike my issue
have you talked your issue I've been
doing cardio like a madman maybe some
Serena's getting tweets of advice about
this
I had cardio like a madman but like
Jordan shorts on and I don't know what
happened my balls my ball one of them
was just did I just did too much walking
in one day and I had a little chafing
issue on one side of the old bag there
and it did not infect my enjoyment of
the band because the I I walked like
it's like a two-mile walk over there or
something right what are you doing
you're looking at me looking at her two
miles over and then two miles back and
that way after I already done an hour of
cardio so the next day I was walking
like I wrote a horse for like six weeks
straight but anyways I went over I saw
this show and they have a singer uh
Martin Johnson mazing singer and then
two killer guitarists I hope they say
these names right Kieran J there you go
Khalil Ian max Bernstein and then they
had a guy sitting in on bass Andrew Peru
see and dude they sounded [ __ ] I mean
it's really like poppy type stuff but
the level of musicianship how great they
all sounded live
definitely check it out once again it's
called the name of the band is the night
game and the single is the outfield and
that is out right now
so can we talk about your chief balls
huh oh it's done it was just it was one
and done was one day of
uncomfortableness oh you're okay now
oh yeah good okay I was suggesting that
Bill get gold bombs medicated powder
because I just felt like that was just
something that you just dust on your
balls a little bit we kept said you know
like when those great chefs put the
powdered sugar on beyond the confection
sugar and do that little bit no I think
that's your balls a little bit to keep
but that's not for chafing it's not no
that's but I thought that's what people
who have itchy balls itchy balls and
their sweaty and so therefore so kind of
like it's a culture like you're gonna
make bread but it's your balls Oh bread
balls
that's disgusting no this is just uh
yeah chafing you don't I mean Gary
Chaffey ah she's chiming in this the
third Mike um anyway sings it's funny
anyways yeah so that is uh that is over
this is gonna be difficult ly down but
you know we got the third men don't know
well this is YP that the heads to me why
you know on Twitter like we haven't been
on the podcast a while because I you
know I have said I have to watch her
yeah she look how happy she is she's
such a happy baby I'm actually psyched
that she's really chill and so people
keep saying she's a really relaxed happy
baby which is unbelievable considering
she lives with me should I've been doing
I've been going really hard with the
whole trying to be chill right yeah a
good job all going really hard with the
chili yeah hey y'all gotta take it to
the extreme I know and you said to me
that day have did you have you been
meditating lately that's when I know I'm
getting a little up to the little press
apiece there press apiece yeah so I got
it uh I got a [ __ ] I got a handle
that type of stuff so um hey the Celtics
got the number one seat the number one
let number one seed in the East so we
get to see seed se EDC what I put in you
to have that baby except this is like
this is you
yes that's a good point the Bulls are
going to definitely be tough we're not
trying to look past them uh-huh
and it just was a great night as far as
you know considering the tragedy of
yesterday the Bruins win the Habs Lou
wait but tell me what a seed is again
just like you know they'll have whatever
there's ten teams you just ranked on the
number one seed means you have the best
record why do they use the word seed you
know what I don't know mm-hmm no I'm
saying that right snot yeah number one
seed yeah the I don't know why they call
it that is what is positioned what are
you going to call so then when you get
to the collapse you rewarded for having
your best for having the best record
what number one gets to play the lowest
person that just made the playoffs so
you get to kind of go an easier way to
go through class and it's also it kind
of makes it so when you get to the later
routes that the best teams are playing
and the stakes are even higher okay this
is to go to the NBA final gotcha this is
to go to the you know this is to win the
whole damn thing except in hockey hockey
of course they do everything weird where
you know for whatever reason like
Pittsburgh has to play the Blue Jackets
and I would have thought that I was like
the Capitals I would have thought they
would have got Toronto I don't know I
don't get how they do it over there but
that's definitely hockey but we won we
won the [ __ ] and now sorry I'm all
distracted today I have to read some
advertising there's anything you want to
give me [ __ ] about my balls are better
than it was only one of them good well I
mean I'm glad you used what I gave you
for them and I'm also like a a I'm like
a plane you know what I mean like above
those big jet planes they can lose one
engine and still fly so I'm fine
actually I know why was it only the one
ball I don't know why is one ball bigger
than the other is that why it's like
rubbing a little bit more no is it like
how you know women you know what it
brought your boobs are different sizes
no it probably has more to be with my
awful posture my back being [ __ ] up in
one shoulder in front of the other one
I'm just a mess hmm I'm all from all
this years I hang it on to the anger and
not stretching I'm just to twist it up
mess but I tell you I have been
stretching I've been going to a
chiropractor
and of a masseuse regularly for almost
like a year and had I not done that god
knows what would have I would have lost
a nut what I still need to know because
I asked you and you weren't sure what a
jockstrap is used for drug strap it's
not the same as a cup no its exact Troy
get good
it holds all your you junk but it just
has no consideration whatsoever for your
ass I've never understood I've never
understood it's sort of the mail phone
and if you don't want like guy underwear
lines I don't know why your ass is all
the way out really I don't know what it
is I don't know what the for purse or
sports though it's called a jockstrap
it's for a job well let's look it up
let's have this on my search engine
what's the deal what's the deal with
what's with why jock straps yeah a jock
strap is also known as a jock jock strap
strap supporter or athletic supporter it
is an undergarment for supporting the
male genitalia during cycling sports or
other vigorous physical activity oh it's
a sports bra for your penis yeah for
your junk flop all over the place yeah
but evidently you don't mind if your ass
is hanging up and now commonly worn is
everyday underwear fashion jobs wraps
appear in variety of colors do they yes
they do well now you got to go image new
here you go you want to look at some
designer jock straps I actually really
do let's go there you go Wow is one for
you it's a great a sling that guy oh my
god that was like reverse Victoria's
Secret that was [ __ ] horrible
alright is your answer you had a nice
ass exciting you have to have a nice ass
if you're gonna model those things right
yeah it's like if nobody wants to look
at you know the same way a woman with
the flat ass and a thong is one of the
worst things you could ever seek yeah
you need to literally
you don't like it doesn't disappear you
can see the whole you can see the whole
thing that's right all the way to the
front okay well I got to do some sort of
I got to do a little reading out loud
and I don't want my daughter to know how
dumb I am so if you guys I'm not kicking
you out but I'm just saying if you want
to block your ears your muffs here
um you read to her all the time eery
great I actually do a good job with
those books yeah but you know you also
ad-lib throughout the entire book kind
of like the way you do advertising yeah
you you know maybe we're the ducklings
we was like this weird thing with the
guys the Ducks like an absentee father
he has like six kids what there's that
guy taking off going to Boston Common
I'll meet you over there it's like I
trust you you're a good mother and she's
just like yeah well you know I am she
did everything but say yeah this is
where I belonged
when grant the book was written in like
the 30s of the 40's and then the The
Little Mermaid yeah Little Mermaid II
were yeah that whole thing was weird
it's like she looks up love at first
sight with the prince yeah he's got his
own effing boat can't curse when she's
here I probably already did though
you did huh that's okay that's alright
nice little cutie pie girl Kirsten I
think it's hilarious that warms my heart
no all right up side everybody okay
here's some advertising sorry okay hey
guys I discovered something really big I
can tell you I have no idea what this is
so I haven't discovered anything I'm
just reading the [ __ ] then the best new
way for you to buy travel it's called
upside calm here's why I love it even
though I've never seen it and why
everyone I tell loves it every time you
buy a trip at upside you save a ton of
money and they give you an amazon gift
card worth 100 200 even 300 dollars
every time that makes no sense how would
they make any money like a plane ticket
cost 300 bucks you get a 100 bucks back
what do you flying people's Express you
own your valujet there the way the way
they do it is really clever upside
bundles your flights and hotels together
for one low
price bundle prices saves money others
how they do it especially giving you the
secret formula especially on business
travel so upside gives you free Amazon
gift cards I'm telling you if your
frequent business if you're a frequent
business travel your company saves a ton
of money and you can get a get thousands
a year thousands a year just for buying
your air and hotel together at upside
plus oh god this is so long you still
get all of your miles Jesus Christ
these guys are given the whole thing
away you'd be crazy not to check out
upside comm if you're shopping the
business pretty for business or personal
travel it takes just three months to see
how much you save by buying your flights
and hotel together at one low price I
can't believe it's taken this long for
someone to do it evidently possibly just
possibly discussed speaking with Jay
Walker here I don't know who that is
and check out what I've arranged for you
use my name Burpee you are our you're
guaranteed to get at least $200 Amazon
gift card for your first trip my name
Burpee you are our gets you at least
$200 in case you didn't hear that two
seconds are going Amazon giftcard for
free how can you not do it it's a
no-brainer say big on travel and get big
gifts sorry they capitalize those card
big gift card every trip upside calm
upside calm minimum purchase required
see the site for complete details I can
tell you that almost sounds too good to
be true
[Music]
why would they want why would they give
you all of that and get you on the plane
I who's behind that new I don't know is
it Isis I don't think all right let me
undies oh oh yeah I get out of here for
the song lives but oh dude do me undies
be undies wearing a nice jockstrap doo
doo doo doo biondi's be undies your
balls are fine but your ass gets the
clap because it's hanging out for the
whole world to see they never see your
junk unless you have to pee by semi
undies your balls are nice then
nice velvet rope it's like you know what
it is it's like when you're wearing a
jockstrap it's like your junk isn't VIP
and your ass is on the dance floor too
soaking in like I love it
hey man can I be can I get in there and
pop some bottles all right me undies
elevate your underwear game to the next
level with me undies you've perfected
your wardrobe but what about this stuff
not everybody gets to see if you've been
settling for store-bought underwear five
packs that a child put in there at 3:00
in the morning in Honduras I have
something that will change your life for
the better me undies what's the first
thing you put on the last thing you take
off its your underwear unless you're
Matthew McConaughey make your most
important piece of clothing the best it
can be with me undies what is me undies
but God's name is it ah just seriously
soft feel good undies delivered right to
your door my undies are designed in LA
Louisiana Los Angeles nobody knows and
made from sustainably sourced micro
modal Modell a fabric three times softer
than cotton allegedly me undies softer
than soft luxury undies come in an
ever-changing selection of classic
colors bold shapes and adventurous
patterns so you can tailor your undies
to your own personal style maybe undies
why don't you make you let's see your
your take on the jock strap with your
modal your micro modal just tick loaded
Elmo down tickle in the taint and guess
what you can save time and money each
month with the monthly subscription if
you're not ready for a subscription
that's okay you can still save relax
that's because we undies is offering you
20% off your first pair just use our
special URL my undies com / / and get
20% off your first pay so go ahead
revamp your underwear drawer
you deserve it once again that's my
undies dot-com / / me undies com / /
alright Jesus Christ two more to go hey
Nia have you ever heard of LegalZoom I
have but good your Monday morning
podcast oh that was wonderful
number one reliability more than a
million people have already trusted
legal so to help start their business
and corporations LLC's nonprofits DBAs
and more use legal zone to get started
the right way
but to experience you can count on
LegalZoom for all the details
they've been helping all types of
business owners for over 15 years
they're not afraid you walk in another
jackass with two arms put them in a
shirt go ahead what's your deal they'll
handle it
number three helpful support like a
jockstrap
they have the right people standing by
ready for your question all based in the
u.s. America making it great again
number four already are there legal
advice Legal Zoom isn't a law firm but
they have a network of independent
attorneys oh like better call Saul old
Joe DeRosa crushing it on the first
episode they can review supplier
contracts help with your employment laws
and advise you on many of the hurdles
that pop up when you're running a
business and finally number five no
surprises LegalZoom provides complete
transparency with upfront pricing
customer views and a satisfaction
guarantee
check out legal zone today to see how
they can make life better for you and
your business and don't forget to enter
bird checkout to save even more
legalzoom.com
and lastly but not leastly hey sweetie
you might want some of these huh huh you
know she's got this new she's already
figured out how to make the pout face to
try to manipulate me to pick her up and
you know what god damn it it works every
time all right Dee stl jeans Delta
Sierra tango Lima Jane's great jeans
don't have to they not to be complicated
where's the pepper if you're not Korean
too crazy stitching diamonds and
embedded studs you're not alone I know
that taking a shot at truly religion
jeans are they still in business you
know they are they must be in surely
yeah they're still in business said like
the local Kitty parks with those are dad
jeans now right there all baggy and [ __ ]
know that like how many wear it does
anymore nobody wears if it's over there
was only do cut there's only two people
I knew that bought those in my in my
circle rich Vaughn rich Voss and Bobby
Kelly
both of them they're into those disco
clothes designer Jean definitely I think
one of them had their name in diamonds
on the back of his ass I swear to God
anything I think rich Voss in the back
of his true religion jeans had first
white guy on deaf Jim and in genuine
diamonds was he was he the first white
guy on deaf Jim oh you just made that's
what was on his headshot when I first
met him fat Allaire it was a picture of
him doing deaf Jim oh there you guys
right to show you making history
breaking barriers rights Richard Voss
this is one small step for a white man
one giant leap for all white men
comedians I'm miss rich Bob I don't I
hope you hear this rich go [ __ ] yourself
he's not gonna hear it he's out on a
golf course rich vos has been like
officially retired the way he's been
living since I met him
he lives the good life he golf's more
than Trump by the way I love that Trump
is just golfing his ass off it's the
greatest thing ever you just show you
how like like that job is not that big a
deal
clearly not to him Oh are we talking
about you don't think Obama was playing
high like he played some nerd sport yeah
Obama bathroom no he didn't yes he'd
shot one free-throw every election ever
he's like oh my god he stopping like he
crossed somebody over all right distill
pronounce distilled offers luxury gray
denim and an affordable price jeans that
would normally cost you hundreds DST LD
has started at just 75 bucks they
utilize the same fabrics factories and
wash houses as the best-known brands and
designers while skipping the markups in
the middle Minh the result doesn't say
hey little kid get outta here put them
together the result pure unadulterated
denim without the retail runaround just
go to distill calm spelled est LD calm
and see where minimalist design meets
maximum comfort something you're trying
to sell me a condo they guarantee the
fit timeshare they'll [ __ ] though ship
them to you for free
that's what
that's what a jockstrap is well it's
like a timeshare for your junk ass up
your ass never gets in the house they
guarantee the fit though ship them to
you for free and give you favor turns
until you find the perfect pair des TLD
distilled has been featured in Forbes
times and TechCrunch as well as on denim
clad celebrities in GQ and vogue with
Jay Leno who's at denim clad celebrity
that you know John Travolta during urban
cowboy denim clad celebrities yeah like
they wear denim all the time
they're cladded in it if you cladded
khalad distilled is the only place in
the u.s. you can get this quality of
denim for this price point you can find
their amazing selections of outerwear
leather jackets t-shirts and more using
the same principles of high-grade
materials at low end cuffs all of a
sudden I got the hiccups even
celebrities are wearing distilled I've
got a pair named the Jean style and they
the fit is perfect you know what I can't
fit in them yet really I thought you did
maybe I did when they first gave him
then I went up to a buck 90 when we went
over to Europe and I was smoking cigars
and so now look nice though I love those
jeans on you oh yeah they look even
better folded up on my shelf I I'm down
to 176 there you go I was 180 for a
couple weeks back
I'm down eight pounds very proud of
myself even celebrity of it distilled is
your answer to elevated style without
elevated prices just go to distilled
calm slash / right now get 10% off your
first pair that's distilled calm DST LD
calm / / for 10% off right now Mia do it
let me hear you
DST Otto Delta Sierra tango Lima Delta
nice calm / firm alright look at that 38
minutes went by just like that so that
is the podcast one last shout out I got
to tell you we love what jr. remember
that guy I can't say fu beef was this
song I know I've already dropped the
f-bomb but I'm trying to I'm trying
people alright he has a new album coming
out wheeler Walker Jr's new album
wheeler Oh wheeler is coming out June
2nd and can be purchased now on Amazon
pre-purchase sorry on Amazon and on
iTunes that's my birthday
what is June set really what when this
is album coming out June 2nd
that's my birthday I always forget
always even sorry not a second or the
third do you really yeah is that true
you're not that important to me oh my
god but you know what I used to think
your birthday was on the 8th but we're
not good with dates no we're not we
don't want you anniversary likes ones
are twins I don't tell these people but
can you name our wedding anniversary I
always get confused so do I that's fine
if we tell them oh no okay something has
to be fries like no so that's scary well
we never show pictures from it um so you
don't know I do
it's either is it start with a one or
two it does with the two but I don't
know what the second number is this is
great cuz now I can never get in trouble
you'd be like you're on the road on our
anniversary it's like what did you look
it up you don't even know what it is I'm
fairly certain that I know it yeah
that's it do you know it I had to think
about it the other day obviously we know
the month but yeah we got that going
right how does this relationship work I
don't know but it's been going for 13
years so obviously we're doing something
right and we have this well you skate it
away from that really quickly oh I did
yes let's not try to analyze this let's
not pull any that's right sticks out of
the popsicle house here um so what's
going on today am i watching her at all
yes when um
when uh well you're especially watching
her later today while I get my eyelashes
alright cool you want to watch some
playoff hockey the Blackhawks are
playing tonight there you go huh no and
also while I take a shower and try to
feel human okay cool all right like
that's it all right that's the podcast
for this Thursday have a great weekend
and that's it once again check out all
the stuff I told you to check out that I
now don't have in front of me
Davey Lich's band the hell did I say the
nightlife why am I the worst night game
night game wila Walker juniors new album
and uh was that huh okay that's it they
get it we have a baby stuff and yeah
that's it that would be the podcast I
will check and I'm not checking you I'll
talk to you on Monday have a great great
weekend you see notes I can't say it
she's here she's here could you get out
of the room please yeah so I can deliver
my tagline ah all right there they go
the two beautiful ladies all right have
a great weekend you cut hey what's going
on it's bill burr and it is the Monday
morning podcast for Wednesday April 15th
that's when I'm recording this anyways
and a buddy of mine tomorrow is going to
help me upload this [ __ ] thing onto
my computer and then on to the G casting
and hopefully they did it and if they
did you're actually listening to it you
know and this is my new recording device
how does it sound huh you like this you
like it sound good its stereo
[ __ ] finally after years of you
people bitching at me about the sound of
my cell phone and you know the tapping
of my computer and all that type of [ __ ]
I am 90% there to having a really great
sounding podcast I'm going all out you
know I'm getting a microphone this thing
has the ability you can actually stick a
cord in there have a
microphone and I'll be able to walk
around like Mike Douglas when I do these
and I think it's just going to help the
quality all the way around I hope it
sounds good
I hope that uh you know I listened back
to a couple years you can literally hear
the echo in my room because that's the
way I live my life very sparsely very
sparsely furnished apartment
you know I yeah that's how I love my
life I throw [ __ ] out all the [ __ ]
time you know you ever see like these
people by the time they're 60 years old
you know they're [ __ ] sleeping on
their roof because every time they went
to a baseball game and it was headband
day they they they just took it you know
in it you don't have to take that [ __ ] I
always just said I don't want it and
they look at me like what do you mean
you don't want it I'm like I don't like
clutter you know I don't need a [ __ ]
Baltimore Ravens towel to wave in the
[ __ ] air I don't you know maybe I'll
take it no jerk-off and the super 8
later out bill why why you know it was
so family-friendly right up into that
moment no I'm just saying I don't have a
I don't know a lot of stuff you know but
the stuff I have is quality and it means
something to me I've noticed something
about myself anytime I say anything kind
of sensitive I have to say it in a gay
accent to mask the fact that I feel
uncomfortable opening up you know so
anyways let's get on with this this is
the Monday morning podcast I do one of
these every single week unless there's a
little sort of glitch with my host which
is the first time it's ever happened so
just bear with me and just go with this
I do one of these every week I think I
think I've earned the right to say that
all right and I answer people's
questions people sent me their list of
overrated underrated they asked me for
advice for some godknows reason and
lately people don't send sending me
stories about revenge but here's a new
topic that I guess this guy was trying
to say I introduced and I kind of
dropped the ball on it but I don't know
this is pretty good
talking about songs that annoy him which
are basically any top 40 song songs you
hear all the time and or maybe like I
think the topic he was talking about was
annoying things in sports and I brought
up how at the Red Sox home games they
play Sweet Caroline I believe during the
seventh-inning stretch that's how much I
hate that song is I'm a huge Red Sox fan
and I don't even know when they play it
I believe that's when they do it I
always just I just turned the channel I
can't handle it and you know I know I'm
from there and I don't shouldn't be
trashing Red Sox fans but I don't give a
[ __ ] but if you go to Fenway Park and
you start singing along to that song
with your arm around your girlfriend and
you all look up in the air and you go
bum bum bum
you're a [ __ ] embarrassment you're a
[ __ ] embarrassment stop doing that
isn't it bad enough that we have a
mascot now for the Red Sox you know what
I mean maybe it's because I don't have
any [ __ ] kids but you know can we be
men you know is that like against the
rules now
you know a long time ago I might have
talked about this before but a long time
ago back in the day I want to say was in
the 70s this is why the Internet's great
because you can look this up I swear to
god they tried to have a mascot okay it
was called the Fenway freak I swear to
god this is true and the thing lasted
about three days three days and one trip
out into the bleachers and I don't know
who that poor bastard was that was
inside that [ __ ] suit but he got
pelted mercilessly with any and that
that's back in the day when when it was
bat day you actually got a bat you got a
full-size [ __ ] bat they wiped out a
whole acre of rainforest for every
[ __ ] row of people and this guy got
the [ __ ] kicked out he only got beat up
but he you know it was definitely
expressed that we don't need a [ __ ]
mascot you know this is back in the day
too when a foul ball came into the
stands he didn't give it to a kid you
stepped on a kid to give yourself
another
foot of height so you could steal it
from some other [ __ ] guy that's how
it worked you know but now you know we
got it give it to a kid [ __ ] the kid
give it to a kid did he pay for his
ticket is he paid for parking hasn't he
gotten enough you know you ever realize
how lucky you are was a kid you ever
think about that [ __ ] when you were like
no Matt when you were like six years old
you just had no money you went outside
to play with no ID no money no keys to
the house just empty pockets and you
just [ __ ] went outside and somehow
you know it all worked out try doing
that as an adult walk out of your house
without your keys identity or any sort
of [ __ ] money and I challenge you to
walk around the block away from where
you live without collapsing in a full
panic attack these [ __ ] kids they
don't know how good they got it and
they're going to get a foul ball on top
of it [ __ ] you god damn it I hate that I
don't know I don't know if I hate kids
or I hate their parents I don't know
what it is I like kids you know what I
like I like I saw a kid the other day
this toddler you know what's funny about
toddlers you know and they're like 2
years old he's you know parents always
have him like running around shirtless
they always have like that little beer
belly it's the funniest [ __ ] I cannot
not laugh when I see that [ __ ] because
what I love is this so like not even
self-conscious anybody else I got always
sucks it in but when you're 2 years old
you know give a [ __ ]
just walk they look like little truck
drivers I just think this shit's
hilarious so anyways what am I talking
about so so this dude was basically
talking about just talk about you know
the new topic maybe is things that annoy
you in sports and for me I mean I picked
on my own team and I also I think I
mentioned I can't tell if this guy was
bringing it up or if I had mentioned it
before but less I'll give him credit and
agree with him is when they have that
old cop come in and he sings god bless
Amer
Rocka in Yankee Stadium like I've never
wanted to throw a toaster through a flat
screen more when he gets up there and he
does that whole long beginning there's a
blahblah Bolden just [ __ ] goes on for
like 19 minutes it's Jeff it's just the
worst yeah I don't know I hate that
whole thing I also hate how the Yankees
play new york new york whether they win
or lose it just seems bizarre to me and
it was really funny the night when the
Red Sox finally beat him and hung the
biggest joke in professional sports
history around their [ __ ] necks and
the second it's over the Red Sox are
jumping all over their field and they're
playing that [ __ ] song pop that bad
at it that's bread news is everybody up
stop teary-eyed I don't maybe it's a
tradition I have no idea but um speaking
of which ESPN recently did a top 25
jokes
of all time and the Yankees of 2004 were
nowhere on the list
they had like Greg Norman I was really
surprised by that
but I guess it's because you know when
you dominate an entire century you know
eventually you're going to have a bad
year so I kind of understood it and of
course the Red Sox made the list I think
we were number seven through 18 I think
we were at the top we had the top 11
[ __ ] jokes of all time
but anyway speaking of did anybody watch
the Masters I actually played nine holes
of golf a par three and I've never given
a [ __ ] about golf I never kept score I
used to sneak into a private golf course
when I was a kid with my buddy during
the winter time you know when it was no
snow on the ground and we would play
golf but it was more like it was more
like polo you know it wasn't a stroke
thing it was more like who could get the
ball in the hole first so there was a
lot of
you know standing in front of somebody
off to the side as they were shooting
and you were shooting too and he [ __ ]
slices it and the hitch in your back you
know that kind of [ __ ] and then you play
like five holes and then you don't give
a [ __ ] and then you just start trying to
drive golf balls at the building next to
the golf course we play golf like that
so anyways long story short I actually
had a good time on this par three course
and I actually parred one of the holes
and I started be like man I think I
might want to play this [ __ ] game so
I got [ __ ] I watch the Masters I'll
see what's going on you know I bet a
little money with my good friend Keith
Robinson who he's part of my my I think
he made the first row of my top nine
thousand friends and he's he's a man of
African descent so you know I'm sick of
them talking about Tiger Woods and how
[ __ ] great he is in all this [ __ ] so
I called up Keith and I tell him that
you know what I'm willing to bet against
Tiger I'm willing to put my money on a
[ __ ] white man to beat the Tiger
Woods you know so he goes I'll take it
if at 20 bucks they picked he'll
Mickelson and I beat that [ __ ]
by one stroke so anyway so I get totally
into this masters and I'm watching the
end of it thinking it's going to be this
very cool thing it was most unsatisfying
winning of a championship I've ever
experienced as a fan because the guy
Kenny Perry 48 years old he had the
[ __ ] thing one OK he birdies 16 he's
up by two strokes with two holes to go
he bogeys the 17th bogeys the 18th and
then loses a two round playoff it was it
was one of the saddest things I've ever
seen and it's like what I really
realized is Golf is the worst sport to
choke in because you choke in anything
else let's take the Red Sox the ball
goes through Buckner's like how long did
that take how long did that take like
what like [ __ ] two and a half seconds
dude this guy Kenny Perry choked for
like 90 minutes an hour and a half on
national television slicing it hooking
it going into the trap
front of his whole [ __ ] family has
shown his family that died in a slow
death his [ __ ] wife couldn't even
look at him at the end of it it was just
it was was [ __ ] horrible I actually
woke up the next day thinking about
going God if he just chose a different
club I don't know if you're a Kenny
Perry fan or you know I feel real bad
for that guy was one of the worst
[ __ ] things I've ever seen in my life
so I don't think I'm ever going to watch
golf again I'm done with it although I
might start playing it and thus complete
the circle of being a white man you know
isn't that what I'm supposed to do cross
my legs with penny loafers and start
pontificating like I know how [ __ ] works
as I wait to tee off isn't that what I'm
supposed to be doing you know certainly
by the time I'm 50 dressed like I'm in
the three stooges sketch I thought I
always do it dressed like in there in
the 1920s and they wear one of those
Black Panther Berets but it has a pom
pom on it all right I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about let's get
back to this kids list this kid made a
list of his top eight which I love
whoever people do a top five top three
top ten who does a top eight I'll tell
you who this [ __ ]
he's doing his top eight songs that just
he never needs to hear again he
basically said if I were all-powerful I
would begin by outlawing these things
which i think is a great new topic to
another new topic okay not only do you
got the things that annoy you in sports
how about what if you were a dictator
and you could make laws what would you
outlaw and this he's this kids just
going with music alright number eight
he said sweet Caroline as I just went
off on number seven Hotel California he
goes I don't give a [ __ ] where you're
living it up you overrated pansy he's
got a lot of anger towards all these
artists Hotel California can we can we
admit that that song never needs to be
played again
piano man horrific song horrific song he
know what's the worst part of this song
is I think it's in 3/4 isn't it saying
is
one two three one two three one two
three one two three one and everybody
starts [ __ ] rocking back and forth
like they're at Oktoberfest that's
that's the [ __ ] you know it's a great
moment in a bar and I swear to god it's
right out of a Benny Hill sketch you
ever see somebody with a beer in their
hand and they check to see what time it
is and their watch is on the same hand
is it's never not funny I saw a guy we
were drinking after an LA Kings game and
you're like when you go to make a point
like you know what the [ __ ] and you kind
of throw your hands out to the side he
did that with a full bear in his hand
and literally just threw like it looked
like a lake of beer onto this this table
whether it was like you know three women
sitting at which made it even funnier
you know what I mean cuz they're all
just like well I never um anyways
anyways let's let's continue it number
number five livin on a prayer absolutely
I would say the entire Bon Jovi catalog
other than that wanted song that's a
guilty pleasure it's on my [ __ ] iPod
I'm not apologizing for it and I
actually learned how to play the
beginning on the guitar and it made me
happy I'm such a [ __ ] loser alright
number 4 Sweet Home Alabama that's still
one that's on the fence it's such a good
[ __ ] song but yeah they've really
played the hell out of it and I love how
I think somebody rapped over that I
think I talked about this before some
rapper rap to that sample and it's been
in a couple of movies that I noticed
black people kind of start bobbing their
heads when that song comes on and if
you're black you should really look up
the lyrics to that song and I don't
think you'd be bobbing your head you
probably be shaking it alright number 3
mustang sally' yeah that songs for like
cougars chicks to start [ __ ] shaking
that dusty muffs to you know is they
grind up on some [ __ ] 20 year old kid
who really wants to bang you because
he's got some sort of weird issue with
older women because his mother didn't
stick around that whole Cougars
is just the creepiest it's it's every
bit as creepy as the 50 year old guy
dating that the [ __ ] 18 year old
chick that whole daddy thing going on
it's just it's really it's creepy but
I'm gonna go ID if I was 15 single and I
could how long would you go you ever
think about that
like right now I'm 40 gonna be 41 in
June 25 25 s might cut off maybe 24 she
listened to jazz you see mature yeah all
I know is you can't be in college I'm at
one time when I was 35 I hooked up with
the 21 year old and in the process of
air quotes here seducing her I actually
said so what's your major and I almost I
almost pulled the plug right there but
fortunately my dick was running things
at that point and I was able to see the
mission through all right number two uh
brown-eyed girl I don't mind that song
Van Morrison you know maybe it's is that
fan Morrison you and my brown-eyed girl
do you remember when oh yeah you know
that's one of those songs that everyone
sings in a bar and it just makes you
hate humanity I'll give you that one and
his number one song is American Pie oh
yeah that's it that's a song that's like
really dramatic for no reason
even though I know they're sick they're
singing about the Big Bopper and Richie
Valens and Buddy Holly all dying this
wasn't the guy to do the song he just he
just really slow and you know Madonna
did a cover of that song talked about
you know to horrific worlds colliding
I'll tell you this if I if I could if I
could pick my top I'll just give you my
top three number three is the entire
Beyonce catalog and that includes all of
her work with Destiny's Child Destiny's
Child I think she's a beautiful woman
she's a great dancer but she cannot sing
I think she's singing too high
and then and then it's just it Oh those
[ __ ] I haven't heard hooks like that
since the last time JLo had a [ __ ]
album out moving that song she had out
and they just kept playing that
saxophone over and over again then Annie
didn't did did it did it did it did it
and you just wanted to [ __ ] smash her
glass into the person next to you like
they like punish you with the music
that's what like Beyonce's songs are
like I don't get it like Beyonce sing as
high as you can and then sing the same
thing over and over and over and over
and over again I mean it 20 minutes left
yeah yeah all her beauty goes down the
[ __ ] drain the second she starts
singing Jesus I'm in a mood so all her
entire catalogue um anything by kiss and
I'm gonna pause here to let everybody
they all Jesus cries kids come on man
just go Detroit Rock City it all sucks
it's horrific and you can take [ __ ]
Bob Seger with them a lot of bad white
music coming out of Detroit
I'm telling you um and the number one
would be Thin Lizzy the boys are back in
town and they should be like a contest
like just just see how long you can
listen to that song it's like they're
just singing about these [ __ ] this
group of douchebags that just like
thinks they're badasses I guess you know
haven't I talked about this before I
can't even [ __ ] remember I've done
some of these podcasts think of it the
boys are back in town they got that hope
the bull if the boys want to fight you
better let them really or else what
you know ma'am and that chicks slap
Johnny in the face man we fell about the
place you know like everyone's just
sitting around this town waiting for
these [ __ ] douchebags to show back up
you know come back into town you know
all [ __ ] the boys are back in town hi
the women these [ __ ] nerds are back
in town and if they want to fight you
better let them whoever wrote that song
should seriously consider killing
themselves you know it's right up there
with Woodrow Wilson pushing through the
Federal Reserve Act that's number one
and number two is whoever wrote the boys
are back in town that's how I see that
[ __ ] all right so let's move on here
let's get on with the podcast what do we
got here what do we got here all right
this here is not really a revenge story
this is actually dare I say kind of
clever what this guy did to [ __ ]
somebody over he this is what he did he
took us I don't know a lot of his
computer stuff so I'm gonna try to read
this slowly and God knows we all know I
suck at reading out loud at this point
all right he says I took us basically
what I did was I took a screen capture
of my friend's desktop when he left his
computer unattended which basically
means he took a picture of the guy's
desktop I guess he didn't have anything
on the screen he just took a picture of
it he goes I then hid all his desktop
icons and set the background as the
screen capture
I just took so basically it looks like
all his all the folders and icons are
still there but they're not so when the
dude comes back you'll be clicking til
his [ __ ] mouth starts smoking and
nothing will happen Nick come on man you
got to give this guy an A for effort
that's just pretty I think that's kind
of ingenious so anyways I guess this is
how it plays out he goes I waited for
the guy to return to see his reaction
because I stood off any distance like a
[ __ ] stalker he goes at first I could
see the really confused look on his face
but it very quickly turned to
frustration and then anger he began
mumbling [ __ ] like this [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] and it escalated to him pretty much
yelling and saying I'm going to smash
this [ __ ] he goes I couldn't
believe it he was pounding the keyboard
and slamming the mouse I was laughing so
hard that snot was coming out of my nose
so the
concluded that he had a virus so he took
the computer to the IT department they
figured it out in five minutes and told
him he's an [ __ ] what do you think
that I do good or am I the douchebag of
the week nah dude you did great that's
[ __ ] hilarious that's a great idea
wish I knew something about computers I
would try that on somebody I try that on
my girlfriend this kind of guy I go no
you're not a douche so that's a I don't
know if you came up with that but that's
pretty yeah that's pretty ingenious so I
give you a thumbs up on that one and
everybody at work go ahead go try that
on your boss no I don't do it to your
boss because someone will end up ratney
out and eventually even if they didn't
rat you out they could figure out that
you were the one who did it because you
would be doing that you know that laughs
and you didn't in school when you were a
kid you weren't allowed to laugh and you
would hold your nose so you'd start
making those duck noises that usually
gives away that you're the one who
[ __ ] did it
all right let's get on with revenge
stories before I get on with the revenge
stories some woman was letting me know
why females are better at revenge than
guys and she wrote a pretty interesting
thing here she says because I guess I
was asking on my podcast a couple weeks
ago how come is revenge only a guy thing
how come I'm not hearing from women and
believe me if you hear the stories this
week I really opened the floodgates
because the women the ladies they came
in strong this week so before I read all
the women revenge stories here this
woman his there's a little preamble set
up she gives me she goes bill you've
only read one revenge story from a
female and I'll tell you why guys are
idiotic and deal with anger so stupidly
is stupidly a word is it a guy's are
idiotic and they deal with their anger
in a stupid way
I don't know I'm too [ __ ] stupid to
know but that would be hilarious if
stupidly is not a word you know because
you just made yourself look like an ass
and if you didn't I apologize let me
continue [ __ ] up someone's car is
pathetic
this kind of revenge is temporary doing
something like that would just make
someone think of you as a [ __ ]
jackass
and then they'll move on with their
lives women can and will remember my new
details and situations that guys will
forget when we want to know what when we
know how someone works we know how to
use it against them physical is
temporary psychological is permanent
women can do the most damage with the
least effort we don't aim to screw
someone over or to do something to piss
someone off we aim for resentment
resentment is much more powerful because
it places you in a higher status and
when someone resents you it's most
likely that you have something that they
don't and that you are just better than
them in some way so my point is that
lashing out at someone is stupid it only
makes you feel better
and doesn't really have or accomplish
much longtime effect on the other all
right now I want to tell you something
you guys that paragraph right there is
why I've never gotten married because I
realize that women have that you know
they got that in them you know that
expression hell hath no fury like a
woman scorned that's the deal it's this
weird thing that when they're dating you
and they want to know everything about
you it's this odd thing where half of it
is so they can love the whole you and
the other half is like it's collateral
in case the thing goes bad they have all
this [ __ ] up information that they can
use against you so I know that was
pretty chilling to read that and I don't
agree with their definition of
resentment saying that it means that you
have something that they don't or that
you are just better than them in some
way I don't think I think they resent
you because you [ __ ] him over you know
not because you drive a better car right
I don't know why don't I shut the [ __ ]
up and read the first revenge story
alright here's now this is all from this
is all from women this weekend I got to
tell you something they really really
take it to the next level and yeah
alright let's just get on with this all
right
and this one I'm not going to tell the
street there's a couple of names and
street names in here I don't to get
anybody in trouble so here we go
bill this story is actually not mine but
was a participant you know I'm gonna say
the name squeeze I'm not gonna try to
[ __ ] remember fake names I'm just not
going to say the name of the street all
right right after I graduated from
college I moved to okay I can't say that
my roommates were still college students
and sometimes their friends which were
also my friends we all went to the same
College they'd stay over one of our
friends Jess who still lived in the dorm
was having problems with a roommate Gail
her roommate knew she had an eating
disorder and was spreading rumors about
her writing things on her mirror like
you're fat we let just stay in our
apartment and we started plot started to
plot revenge one of the things we did
was crank call Gail so in case you got
lost in that I guess just as the
anorexic one and Gail is the [ __ ] all
right okay let's continue on one of the
things we did was crank call Gail we we
used the voice from my roommates Mac
computer and typed out some evil [ __ ]
this definitely made Jess feel better
and I guess inspired her to pull the
ultimate revenge jess was a teen model
before she went to college this is the
anorexic girl while in college she
worked at a high scale a high scale
salon on something-something Street
shortly after we crank called Gail just
ran into Gail's boyfriend after work
according to Jess she brought Gail's
boyfriend back to her their dorm room
[ __ ] him in Gail's bed and then called
Gail right after to tell her all the
details
Jess ended up staying in our apartment
the rest of the semester and bought us a
two hundred dollar bottle of champagne
to celebrate the act of revenge at the
time I thought Gail got what she
deserved but in hindsight it made me
realize that women are evil manipulative
[ __ ] yes many women hate being called
fat but it ceases to amaze but it never
ceases to amaze me that women what women
will do to others other women to get
back at him
Wow you know what I mean let me take it
to that level
I don't know who deserved what in that
story but I think the real winner is
Gail's boyfriend you know everyone that
if you're a guy you ever wonder if any
girl was [ __ ] you on a revenge just
to get somebody back you know I don't
think that's ever happened to me I don't
live that exciting a life but I can't
imagine what you what do you say is the
guy is she sitting there banging you
yeah that'll show her flip over and I'll
bust it on your face you really taught
her a lesson
hey anytime you want to teach the
teacher a lesson again just let me know
I really I really really doubt with you
I understand your point here and I think
you're very justified you know you know
really make really drive the point home
is you let me if you let me bang you
again
you know and if you really want to get
the ultimate ultimate revenge you let me
put it in your ass you know I'm just
throwing these ideas out there I mean
this is this is your world you know I'm
just I'm just here to help okay so
that's revenge story number one and I
can see you know you know what it is
it's not that she's [ __ ] the girl's
boyfriend it's that she called him up
called her up and told her about it you
know that's one of the advantages of
women is for the most part they don't
have to worry about the other woman
coming over and just beating the [ __ ]
out of her
because as a guy if you ever tried to
get back another guy and you banged his
girlfriend you'd never call the dude
because I don't even care if you could
beat the guy in a fight on a normal
basis you know what I'm saying the level
of anger that he would have I think he'd
still win right he's let me get he sense
all right let me plow ahead Jesus Laurie
up to 31 minutes let me get through
these here all right hey Bill here's my
story of revenge everybody knows that
women hate each other hate other women
and I have a great story about women's
revenge I was roommates with two other
women in college when was very average
looking and one was very beautiful the
type of beautiful that makes all the
other girls around our hater she got
whatever she wanted throughout her life
because
because of it guys money grades you name
it and she was a [ __ ] she used everyone
around her and was never said no to so I
was casually dating a guy and brought it
back to my house and both my roommates
were there we hung out with them for a
while and everything was cool I didn't
notice anything unusual a few weeks
later hear from a mutual friend that my
roommate I guess the hot one was out
with my guy
after seriously interrogating my guy he
finally spills his guts and tells me the
truth I would have loved to have seen
that guys are the worst liars ever no I
wasn't [ __ ] 12 seconds later alright
alright you got me I was [ __ ] her
anyways he goes she had the hot girl had
bumped into the her boyfriend on campus
one day and I guess they hit it off and
started seeing each other behind my back
naturally I dumped his ass but I'm so
much more pissed at her I kind of read
that weird so it's her boyfriend okay so
anyways I come up with a brilliant plan
to get my revenge on her and enlisted my
other roommates for help she agrees
because all average girls secretly hate
pretty girls this is really eye-opening
about the the psycho in a world of women
this is like an HBO one to cover so
anyways here's that revenge we had an
advantage because the hot girl she drank
a lot and we get ripped almost every
other night and I mean really really
ripped we'd wait until she could so one
night we waited until she got loaded one
night and it was the most wasted I have
ever seen her it was like all the stars
were in line for our plan she had
beautiful long corn silk hair oh here we
go
here we go she had beautiful long corn
silk hair was straight off the ass of a
golden retriever
I bought two boxes of black hair dye and
after she passes out we start in I
really wanted to make a statement
so I part her hair down the middle and
only dye half of her head Jesus Christ
after I start I turn into this crazy die
hungry freak I couldn't stop myself I
started dying any part of her body that
I could find I did her eyebrows the
peach fuzz on her chin and lip her
fingers and her arms I'm embarrassed to
say that we even died a lightning bolt
in her pubic hair the funny part was is
she kept waking up telling us to leave
her alone
but we kept going Jesus this this sounds
like a [ __ ] date rape story it's just
that as women so I I guess is it still
funny anybody else getting creeped out
here let's continue here of course we
were too lazy to wash it out so we just
go to sleep and leave the black hair dye
on our roommate for about seven hours I
wake up the next day to her in a towel
towel her hair was soaking wet and she
was beating the [ __ ] out of me with a
shampoo bottle
it was [ __ ] hysterical the dye had
stained her skin along with her hair so
she had dark brown patches all over her
face and body she looked like the
bastard child of Cruella De Vil and
Richard Grieco I don't know who that is
I was so proud of my work you would
think that I got my revenge but this is
a story about her revenge on me this is
a [ __ ] long one here this plot twist
she actually called the cops and they
[ __ ] came and arrested my roommate
and me the evidence was stacked against
us because our hands and arms were also
stained with black hair dye her bed
where the crime was committed was
covered in black dye it looked like an
octopus had been raped in there she
tried to charge us with sexual assault
Papa pubic hair lightening bolt yeah you
know you pull somebody's pants down and
start dyeing their genitals or at least
the area yeah you're going to get in
trouble so anyways after spending all
day in the police station we were
finally let out and the charges were
dropped but when we got back to the
house we were greeted by campus security
and our parents were there too trying to
explain to your dad why you died some
other girls pubic hair not fun the
[ __ ] [ __ ] got us kicked out of the
house and we put on strict probation it
was
big deal we almost literally almost got
kicked out of school the worst part was
when we were moving out of the house
about a week later she shows up with my
ex-boyfriend and she looks amazing she
had died the rest of her hair black and
cut it in this cute short bob style and
waxed off all the body hair she was as
beautiful as ever
and then she writes in capital letters
[ __ ] I felt like such an ass like there
was no way to get back at this [ __ ] I
guess my life isn't over so someday I
will get her back I'll make sure to fill
you in okay well I know you haven't
asked my advice but I think you should
just let that one go there sweetheart
I think you know sometimes you just got
to say [ __ ] it is that unbelievable I
mean things like reverse that and if if
you if you did that as a guy if you did
that same thing as a guy you would
literally be in a prison shower right
now with half a mop handle trying to
fight off five rapists but if you know
you have a vagina the only get it you
just get kicked out of your house it's
not getting credible I still a bit about
that [ __ ] how having a vagina just keeps
you out of jail you know like like give
us see like when a mob boss gets
arrested you know they they never take
the wife you know like she doesn't know
what the [ __ ] he's doing oh I just
thought he was a baker I thought he was
really really good at making cookies and
that's why I had 20 furs and lived in a
lived in a mansion you know what the
[ __ ] he was doing you know and you spent
all that blood money and you and you
don't end up [ __ ] going to jail it's
a there's something about it like they
just done' like remember that movie
monsters ball not monsters ball da
monster where they literally turned a
serial killer into this sympathetic
[ __ ] person I just did you know yeah
you had a rough childhood you know you
got molested well you know who didn't go
write some [ __ ] jokes you don't get a
gun and start shooting with [ __ ]
people and if you do you go to jail that
movie was the worst [ __ ] movie ever
with those cartoon character male
characters that they had in that did you
remember that part where she goes in to
apply for the law office job or
something she comes in there looking
like this strung out hooker and somehow
she's not assured right out of the
[ __ ] office she actually gets in to
the lawyer's office and he's just like
let me tell you something you [ __ ]
skank he's like this over the top I
really hated that [ __ ] movie and I
hate when beautiful actresses don't wear
makeup and then the everybody falls all
over themselves and talks about how
brave it is it was so brave he was so
brave alright let's continue on all
right let me read the last one here bill
for the past two weeks I have made my
girlfriend listen to your podcast
incidentally she loves it this past week
she told me about how she got revenge on
her ex-boyfriend oh this one is brutal
and it's it's very doesn't there's no
fat on this one this one's great because
she doesn't get caught there's nothing
you know I don't know ruin here but this
listen this after that messy breakup she
logged on to their shared JetBlue
account you know they going out you know
I gave a dent leave that taking trips so
they got this JetBlue account and I
evidently they both had the password so
she logs on to it and she saw that the
douchebag and his new girlfriend had
booked a vacation well the morning of
their scheduled trip on the morning of
their scheduled trip she logged on and
cancelled the flight can you imagine
what a pain es that must have been for
them anyway she never saw any activity
on the account again I thought that this
was pretty funny a lot more subtler than
keying someone's car like a little [ __ ]
and whatever and whatever that other
[ __ ] wait I mean this morning whatever
that other [ __ ] girl did on the other
week's podcast wow man that is that is
dirty pool right there if the guy
cheated on you yeah I can see that but
you just had a messy breakup that's
that's been dicta that's really that's
[ __ ] up a lot of these things are
really really [ __ ]
up you know that dying that girls pubic
hair that's that's really you need a
hobby at that point alright why don't I
stop judging people I asked for your
[ __ ] revenge stories now I'm judging
you alright whatever just get too
overrated underrated overrated karaoke
hate it terrible song sung by people who
can't sing you which are usually fat
chicks and gay guys and the off-chance
that you and your drunk friends find
yourself at a karaoke bar singing 80s
hair metal songs there's always those
douchebags that interrupt the fun with a
serious gay country song you know I love
about this guy he says Garrett karaokes
overrated like people actually love it
ok then he says that it sucks and then
in the middle of it he admits doing it
but evidently when he and his douchebag
friends go up there and sing 80s hair
metal songs that's totally fine
you know but when someone comes up to
sing us get got country song they're gay
dude I hate to tell you this but you're
part of the [ __ ] problem
um actually you know what actually if
you sing an 80s hair metal song in a
karaoke thing I'm going to laugh my ass
off and I like that better just as long
as someone doesn't go one of the one of
the [ __ ] tunes those chicks always
end up singing what was that song on
that guy's things about losing his
virginity that oh what a night
that's not ladies in the bag in 63 some
reason women love that [ __ ] song and
there's nothing worse than the female
voice like 12 of them all singing in a
really high voice it's like a car alarm
going off alright I think we're done for
the week are we what are we up to 42
minutes all right ask bill this is this
podcast petering out here I think I'm
doing too much reading and not telling
enough stories alright let's let's read
this one here okay bill I'm almost 26
and a bunch of my friends still love
going to the clubs at night and on
weekends now I'm not sure that I'm if
I'm getting too old for it or just over
I just can't stand people but absolutely
hate going to these places I know as a
guy is supposed to go in there get girls
but I just can't take it anymore
no matter which place it is it always
feels like you should get a mandatory
penicillin shot when you leave because a
group of sweaty skanky people crammed
into a room grindin to crappy techno
music is just disgusting that combined
with the guys with the Sonic the
Hedgehog haircut just drives me crazy
especially when they're the ones getting
all the girls um is it me or these
places truly horrific and at what stage
at what in a what age were you
officially the old [ __ ] at the club um
all right all right dude though you're
being too hard on yourself first of all
you're only 26 years old you're in the
prime of your life you should be going
out talking to women you're just doing
it in the in a bar that's not you you
know what I mean
but basically everybody's a douche bag
okay but you got to hang out with the
same kind of douche bag so you feel
comfortable you know what I mean
like me I'm a loner psycho douche bag so
I used to hang out in dive bars and who
the [ __ ] am I kidding did I that I don't
think I ever picked up a girl in a bar I
always met I met gyms I met him on the
subway a lot in New York I I meet him
when they're not ready you know like
women don't have their guard up
sometimes like on the train they have
the guard up to get mugged not to be hit
on I guess I don't know maybe I just
felt like you know I would never did
well in those singles bars like you know
it's almost like as a comedian someone
goes you're a comedian alright say
something funny
it's just like you've ruined the moment
so I would still go out just find you
know find find the right place to hang
out you can't hang it up at 26 unless
you live in the middle of Kansas then
you might as well [ __ ] read a Bible
and knock up some broad and have eight
kids and vote for a [ __ ] [ __ ] over
and over again for eight [ __ ] years
okay that was a little mean all right uh
question of the week
bill I was wondering how you handle two
shows at one night I was part of the
late crowd tonight and you killed what
was was it the same scenario in the
earlier show with the jokes that bombed
in the earliest show whether jokes in
the in the earlier show that bombed that
you skipped on the second show ah no you
know if it bombed I'm too stubborn I'm
going to keep doing it but doing two
shows in one night I try to switch it up
you know I just don't want the wait
staff and everybody to know exactly how
my acts going to go because that's a big
thing on the second show and you're
three three days into your weekend gig
if you see like the waitresses smiling
and stuff and laughing as they're
bringing drinks over the table that's
like one of the best compliments you can
get because nobody sees more comedy or
listens to more comedy than comedy club
waitresses
because as a comedian if I see a comic
and I don't like what he's doing I can
walk out of the room but as a waitress
you have to got to keep going back in
you know and so you can get the you know
so they get jaded really quickly as far
as like what's funny of them so I don't
know if I answered your question but no
I don't really I know what I'm going to
start with and I know what I'm going to
finish with I don't really know what's
going to be in the middle but I
definitely switch up the jokes just so I
don't feel like like that Groundhog Day
thing where everything's the same so
alright there's that all right bill I've
been listening to your podcast and I
watched you perform because it's nice to
hear to someone use the word [ __ ] every
five minutes you don't seem to curse as
much when you're performing but you're
getting to be like some of the other
dirty comics out there on your podcast I
think it's quite hilarious how you use
the word to describe anyone that's
pissing you off through unnecessary no
unnecessary most of the time in addition
how wait a minute already read this I
already read this deny this is this lady
asked me about st. Patrick's Day that
was from Cleveland I already read that
all right so I guess that is the end of
the podcast for this week please give me
the feedback what do you think about the
new
the new stereo sound I know I need to
make some adjustments I know I might
have been too close to it a couple of
times and I know that there's like an
echo in the room now and I'll put some
empty eggshell crates on the [ __ ]
side of my walls but whatever so so
that's the deal
just to let you know my upcoming gigs
I'm going to be at Iowa State this
weekend April 18th and that is a private
show that show is only for the students
of Iowa State you need a student ID to
get into the show or if you kind of look
young and you have a baseball cap maybe
you can sneak your way in but you didn't
hear that for me the following weekend
I'm going to be at the funny bone in
Columbus and the weekend after that I
will be in Caroline's in New York City
young Joe DeRosa will be performing on
both of those shows and then if you'll
notice on my my website I had to blow
out a number of dates
Tempe Ireland Cleveland and Atlanta are
all being rescheduled and I can't really
tell you why as of yet I'm gonna leave
you hanging how do you like that huh
like one of those old [ __ ] Batman and
Robin's when they're stuck in a machine
and they're gonna [ __ ] die and you
got to wait till next week yeah I can't
really tell you I can't actually I can't
tell you for a minute I kind of
something may or may not be going on and
I needed to free up my schedule and at
some point actually in June I'll be able
to let you know so that's the deal
that's the Monday morning podcast and if
you like this the device I'm using is
the Olympus LS 10 this [ __ ] thing is
it's pretty incredible and I'm going to
have my own mic next weekend me and Joe
DeRosa are going to be continuing our
uninformed show as a podcast on the
myspace.com / uninformed radio and we're
going to be using this device with a
couple of microphones and I think we're
going to be doing an episode next week
and we're going to put it up there and
it's going to sound lovely and that's it
and I feel like I'm boring you so that's
it everybody thanks for listening and
please keep the questions coming and
feel free to keep sending me you know
things from past topics and if you want
to do them for the the new ones songs
your top [ __ ] your top eight songs
that annoy you and [ __ ] in sports that
bugs you alright that's it everybody
have a good